so the winter weather in Mount
Charleston up at Lee Canyon means a lot
of visitors but also a lot of congested
roads but people are leaving their trash
behind too Mary Jane ballessa went up to
Lee Meadows which is a popular sledding
area to take a look
plastic bags old food containers and
even broken sleds are just one of the
many things people leave behind at Lee
Canyon
and the trash doesn't go unnoticed oh
yeah we were just talking about it on
our way back from our car it was really
sad seeing it Daphne Eli and her family
are visiting from Hawaii and always
practice leaving zero Trace we have this
saying from Hawaii or it's like
you and malama means like take care it's
like if you take care of the land it can
take care of you and it's a beautiful
place too so I think that's even more so
why it's important to take care of the
land Jimmy Alderson has lived at Mount
Charleston for seven years he wants to
remind visitors to clean up after
themselves as there are private
residents living on the mountain too A
lot of times we will actually find dirty
diapers uh things of that nature on like
the Bristlecone Trail
um as you walk through there where
someone just decided to toss it instead
of the you know put in a baggie and and
find a trash can every season the
Southern Nevada Conservancy group
arranges a cleanup communications
director Lainey Moet says they typically
pick up more than a thousand pounds of
trash every year unfortunately lots and
lots and lots of pieces of sleds get
left time and then you know once the
snow melts we find lots of little pieces
left but
um in the winter it's good for us to be
able to go out and get those bigger
pieces to help kind of not just clean up
the meadow for an aesthetic standpoint
or an environmental standpoint but for a
safety standpoint friends Kimberly
devrel and Kelly Stanberry brought their
kids sledding along with the box of
snacks and hot chocolate they advise to
bring your own trash bag and take it
with you that's what they plan to do
when they leave the mountain there's so
many wild Burrows that are out here like
it's clearly a really nice environment
in its nature people it's important to
pick up your trash I mean I've thought
about even going and picking some up
before we leave